keith is with us in Lexington Kentucky
hi Keith how are you just fine Dave good
what's your net worth sir
one point four five million cool what's
that invested in it's invested in and
the way you would say to do it mutual
funds and all those categories and also
our home is paid for and then just some
cash okay and what is your age sir
44 years old wow you're a young one okay
and how much of this did you inherit I
didn't inherit any of it but $6,900 was
a gift in a $10,000 CD from my granddad
but when I got married to back home okay
and your range of income and your
working lifetime sir right now it's
anywhere from 80 to 110 okay cool
and what do you do for a living I am a
production team leader in the Toyota
Georgetown plan in Kentucky all been
there
yeah well yes yeah in 2005 in July when
you came there 2005 we got your FB you
kid yeah cool and since then your
degrees in what I have a degree in
industrial engineering okay and your GPA
was a three oh okay cool and how much
money how much of this one point four
five is there because you borrowed money
to invest zero okay and what giving what
part is giving played in your plan we
have we have always given the 10% to the
church and just the Children's Miracle
Network and and also with our time and
things around the community and
community services thanks cool all right
most expensive pair of jeans you ever
bought myself 25 I can't say for my wife
okay all right that's fair and your
advice to the 25 year old version of you
25 year old version is to sacrifice on
the front ends that they can see that
diagram I came here the names of it the
guy invest for eight years to start been
an Arthur you know it is very very true
yeah so it's the sacrifice my dad told
me when I got hired at the network there
to put in as much as I could until I
could not you know
very cool well way to go man 1.45
million I love it at 44 years old you're
an economic hero congratulations and
coming today
proud to talk to you sir I haven't
talked to a single crook what I haven't
talked to a single person that inherited
their money what apparently somebody's
lying out there oh well maybe you ought
to stop it this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in common